you have to drive 90 kilometers north of
the Polar Circle and a long way outside
the town of kalari to reach cabina Vetta
the name of the restaurant means cowshed
made of stone the host is Marty heavy
soil an aperitif I can offer you a Kiva
noventa cocktail you won't find it
anywhere else it is made of angelica
birch vodka lemon a pinch of salt
manicure and a little tonic water human
a Liguria yeah
c10 tonic key deep position bad hair
vestroia does almost everything himself
he's the chef waiter
wine steward and barkeeper all in one
despite this remote establishment he
says he gets guests from all over the
world including royalty and superstars
although he won't name names not bad for
someone who didn't start out as a chef
ela Lolita
actually I'm a metal worker by training
but I couldn't find a job
hey-ya I thought catering would offer
more opportunities I've been a chef for
37 years now and have only been out of
work for one month the whole time
haier vasoya taught himself how to cook
he uses almost entirely local produce
and meat at his restaurant one regional
specialty is willow ptarmigan or grouse
vehicon floppy in its meat is very
popular in Lapland and it's very
expensive the birds come from an area
quite near here I get them from a hunter
who's an expert in bagging now I'll
start preparing the meal
the meat is sauteed briefly and then
goes into the oven for 10 minutes at a
hundred degrees centigrade I serve it on
raku which is made of parsnips dried
reindeer meat barley and carrots the
vegetables are sauteed the reindeer meat
is added and then the gravy from the
grouse
however Sawyer serves it with sauerkraut
the hearts of the willow grouse are a
delicacy around here he fries them for
two minutes in butter
the meat goes on the rock ooh and the
hearts on the sauerkraut
this is a traditional Finnish dish it
can also be made with the meat of other
fowl pterosaur built this restaurant
himself but first he had to teach
himself how he's quite a self-made man
some of the stones in the wall here
weighed more than three tons the stones
were brought by truck from 600
kilometers away a total of 360 tons of
red granite from vesanto in central
Finland I spent two years looking for a
stonemason to put them together but
couldn't find one so I built the walls
myself got the money Kiva Nevada has a
fine wine cellar here Visayas selects
the bottles himself he also designed the
door to the wine cellar
a delicious meal in this stone-built cow
shed in the woods is certainly worth the
long trek